how's the goin breath - parrot welcome
to another oculus rift horror game
mindset I locked all the doors some art
I can't scare me
we're gonna play a game that I'm looking
forward to play for a long time it's
called my air man its fangs mad I mean
when lights die I'm pretty pumped for it
let's do it it's going whoa let's do
this good the experiment it's starting
soon in your profile don't worry it
won't be long okay I'm waiting whoa I'm
just gonna start soon and thanks to the
data we collected listen also later in
detail but do not remove your virtual
reality device okay directly linked to
your cerebral activity hey Trey oh hey
tree yes what something is weird
what's going on oh don't worry we can
fix that
goddamn Trey what what it's going oh you
done [ __ ] up bro baby else yeah why I
said chair doing their chair oh okay
this is creepiest whoa what the [ __ ] did
they say Oh ahh
this is so weird like it really feels
like I'm in the room when I'm really not
which is is that blood oh god no no why
why catch a knife man leave it boy hey I
don't - oh whoa jab blood okay Oh what
the [ __ ]
yeah that was awkward
what what happened what what's wrong
with you
don't make me slap you boy the hell are
you doing go home to mama okay that is
your mom she's hot
what what are you doing I told you to
stay away
yeah [ __ ] I have to go back Matt what
the hell is your problem I would kick
you I will kick you like a little [ __ ]
you are alright fine I'm gonna go back
to the chair and I'm gonna go back to my
trees and it's all gonna be good end up
hood you little [ __ ]
stop following me what listen wasn't in
here okay you are I'm watching you
[Music]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I hate him
all right what do we got boomer doesn't
even jabbed I'd love to fit that I hit
you what is it what do you watch god I
hate kids all right if you're gonna
follow me you need a name and don't
think I'm gonna protective [ __ ] happens
you you're on your own okay okay I'm
gonna call you Matt whoa Manny is that
good
Manny they move
you'd have to try to find the other
chair what would you give you as soon as
you're in it oh thanks
well I find it guys like it's right
there and it's it has a smiley face on
it
[ __ ] okay fine what what okay someone's
coming you stay there you protect me
it's [ __ ] awesome stay there stay
there yeah that's how you stay your
little get stay I'm watching you man
okay
okay I don't know what's gonna happen
there but I don't French people are
coming so okay French people are coming
run crazy what [ __ ] this is so [ __ ]
scary
[Music]
where's a little boy oh god oh god oh
god oh god are they saying they're gonna
eat me don't eat me I tastes like [ __ ]
please don't eat me please
HoneyBaked we're fine we're fine we're
fine
all is good please don't leave me oh god
this is [ __ ] terrifying
[Music]
okay we're gonna go any
Oh what's happening I'm sorry I'm sorry
I can't I can't I said I'm not
exaggerating by one bit it's so [ __ ]
scary okay I I can't I can't
I'm not I refuse to go back in there go
back in it's fine it's just a game it's
just a game it's just a game it's in C
okay I get the [ __ ] out of my way Jack
did the French guy go away yes yes I can
what's up tell me how to get out of here
I just want to live forever and I'm
gonna learn to fly ha
can't I get in the chair please
okay let's check on this place instead
now I'm a name to do oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] on a stick
and then [ __ ] lick it like a po
popopo popopo
okay well fine it's just someone
breathing everyone breathe everyone
literally everything what the [ __ ] was
that
shut the [ __ ] up okay what's in here
whoa whoa
Paula I learn it by Vinny oh [ __ ] okay
okay alright we're going here we go over
here we go over here we go here we go
with it nobody know why
you ugly [ __ ] jeez I hope that was Mayo
Mayo Matt Manny Manny that was me okay
what's going on Oh Judy village a pond
by a hot today [ __ ] brats these days
all they talk about it's pokemons kids
they used to breed now they don't am i
angry about shoes because they always
need new ones okay
where is he
what is shed we're not going there you
sound like a really old squeaky bicycle
nothing against those but [ __ ] man how
about you oil your gears a little bit
yeah come on I don't know nope nope nope
nope nope nope
hope you enjoyed
[Music]
that's tougher